this is actually this is a great
representation of the snacking habits of
Americans versus the rest of impressive
I am Rachel I'm from America hi I'm
Janice I am greekcypriot hi everyone my
name is Karina and I'm from Athens
Greece I'm Brendan and I am from the US
of A and today we are going to be
swapping snacks I'm excited to try
anemic it's nice to be honest kind of
curious does he like what you guys grew
up down and kind of try that how about
you have you got any Greek snacks
I mean I've had Greek food well I know
it's like is Greek food and just like
Mediterranean food kind of the same
thing yeah okay great all right are you
ready to try some snacks then ready oh
[Music]
yeah I'm so excited yeah I see that I've
never seen before these oh okay that
sounds a lot cooler than fudge stripes
I'm already excited about I am so proud
of us right now this is a great choice
this is gonna kick well no it's not
they're very simple it's just like a
little I think it's like a butter cookie
kind of thing but it's got the chocolate
on the bottom with the aforementioned
fudge stripes on top so this is yummy
stuff yummy stuff which means stuffed
I'm sad that I have to give these away
to you right ready one two three
they're gonna eat the whole package chip
[Music]
okay well we're a little late on the
cheers cheers Cheers
I'm loving this you like it I love
biscuit and I love chocolate yeah this
tastes perfect main difference for me
for versus like an Oreo is that the the
flavoring of the actual cookie part is a
lot more kind of like subtle and nice
it's not as like overwhelmingly sweet
the flavor is not so aggressive this
would be great in coffee I need another
one yeah great okay you don't that's
listen I only have like five of these
because they're not American you have
600 of those yeah you know what you can
have oh I think I like these more
because this is very chocolatey and you
can still feel the chocolate in the
biscuit part yeah
this you get a couple bottles of these -
which do you prefer these are an
absolute American classic I prefer these
yeah these are great
I think I'd pick the Fed straight yeah
I've always liked this cookie like it's
just not that aggressive or anything
like that and this one is totally
wonderful like I actually love both of
them aha
I don't like sour cream
I don't eat sour cream or anything but I
love sour cream and onion chips that's
how good these chips are Wow let me tell
you these are way better Wow okay
because I put oregano and everything it
smells interesting like grease that's
very small it's everywhere it's Oregon
ivory where's like Springs like do you
have to swap yes we have to swap take my
dumb chips these are so interesting Wow
like them yeah oh my god may eat the
whole bag it's like they're trying to be
those they're very similar I mean can we
get rid of these real quick yeah I got a
compact it's really really interesting I
love it a lot
I love the onion in here yeah I'm just
gonna be honest I prefer the saganaki
these chips okay I don't I don't think
there's a wrong answer here do they have
any of these with ridges that's a good
question
yeah maybe you didn't even think about
that well you were like she'll never
find out so I'm just gonna say yeah oh I
was hoping you would bring these oh my
god so these are mini croissants as it
says on the package these are many
croissants with cream filling I've been
living in a world in which I did not
know that many stuffed croissants were
available by the mag we would have these
when we were young at school like these
were our snacks they have them in
chocolate flavor and they have
vanilla flavor my god he does dung
cupcake - oh no way you can see the
typeface I get is oh my god
smell it I can feel it smells like
happiness enjoy oh this is great do you
like that combo also has a lot more
filling than these I wish she do there's
cream in the one it's not overwhelming
at all yeah sometimes I would get
annoyed when I was young when one of the
croissants didn't have enough yeah we
don't have that problem in America these
are very good
I do wish that the filling was like a
little more present here's the thing I
think I would only be able to have two
of these oh yeah I may be the whole bag
of this this is dangerous
like I'm nervous that I've tried these
because now I can't go back I can't
unteach how good this is
I mean those are great for me is it as a
winner out of the two please
all day seven days a week
cooling jammers I have never had this
and always wanted when you're a kid you
either have kool-aid jammers or you were
a loser I've never had a cool idea where
my life these pouch drinks are fun
because they're the only single serve
drink that comes with an obstacle course
and that is you have to put your little
javelin through this hole and try not to
puncture the back which will happen
about 40% of the time oh that's on the
first time I'm gonna be really
embarrassed Oh got it
expertly done expertly done good job ha
ha
nothing no wait not even light no oh
that's too sweet it's cooling yeah yeah
this is like a thing that you guys look
yeah oh my god I I would piss up this is
great that is my favorite juice is very
good
down that than there sure is a shame
that you don't have any currently oh no
this I don't even need to hit that one
no comparison this is you feel
disappointed but I didn't like it like
if you were eight
I would have freaking wall this I'm very
impressed by Greek snacks I feel like
the great snacks were a little more
creative
I feel like instead of just like a
cupcake it was like a mini croissant
with cream filling like Annabeth why
don't we have those all over the place
here my favorite American one was
definitely the fudge stripes at the
beginning I like the hostess snack okay
I love the chocolate part but I'm not
like the filling was a little too much
these snacks would definitely make me
want another curious I'm happy yeah that
was my gold yeah I would go to Greece in
a heartbeat I would probably come back
weighing significantly more than I
currently weigh great I'll show you
around yeah let's go
[Music]